[Music]
before we get going
if you enjoy what we do on spectator tv
then do subscribe to our youtube channel
you do this by clicking the button at
the bottom of the video and then tapping
the bell icon to make sure you never
miss an episode ever again
and why not subscribe to the spectator
magazine 2 while you're at it
get 12 weeks of the magazine for just 12
pounds and we'll give you a free 20
pound amazon voucher
completely free do the maths there and
that's three months of the spectator
delivered to your door
and available online for just 12 pounds
did we mention the voucher
just go to spectator.cody uk forward
slash tv offer to take it up
now first pretty patel has introduced a
nationality and borders bill
which could see refugees illegally
coming into the uk jailed and border
officers given powers to use force to
keep illegal
immigrants away is this the right
approach and if it is
is it enough i'm joined now by douglas
murray who is
in this week's cover piece saying more
needs to be done and envers solomon ceo
of the refugee cancer
douglas enver thanks for coming on the
show today
douglas to begin in your cover piece you
note that the number of migrants has
reached record levels
can you talk us through why yes of
course
everyone will be aware that this story
has been developing
in recent years we have
seen across europe in the last decade
an increase in illegal crossings from
principally uh from turkey and from
north africa into
mediterranean europe and we've seen a
trickle
in recent years of a similar movement
across the english channel
from france to usually dover or
around the dover area in the south of
england and
this movement has been a political issue
of a kind
for some time viewers will remember that
in 2018 the then home secretary sanji
javid cut short
his holiday to go and stare at the
english channel
and say that he was getting a grip
on this issue this issue however hasn't
gone away however much
politicians stare at water and
we've seen a very significant increase
in the number of people coming
illegally in recent months and
it's important to get the figures in
some perspective um
the number of migrants arriving was
four times higher last year than it was
the year before
that it was it was almost 2000 people in
2019
and it was eight and a half thousand in
2020 now the number
for 2021 having quadrupled last year
the number for 2021 is already double
that
of last year we've already seen in the
first six months of this year more than
9
000 migrants arriving illegally by boat
across the english channel and we've
also seen
the daily records for that
exceeded with a high in july of 430
people
making the journey in just one day so
this has become an issue
which uh which politicians continues
to pretend that they're going to address
and
continue to not address and as i say in
the piece if they don't
then the numbers will simply grow and
grow because the pool
of people who wish to come to the uk and
who might be attracted by this
idea of a parallel asylum system where
on the one hand there's the legal system
on the other hand there's the first
across the channel
in in a dinghy competition the number of
people willing to do that
is vast across many continents in the
globe
and so i suggest it's a massive issue
that the
the government needs to get a grip on if
it doesn't it'll grow and grow and
become
worse for the government envir do you
think it's an issue that more people are
trying and succeeding in terms of
crossing the channel
well it's important to put this in
context there are far
fewer people coming to this country
seeking asylum
than they were a decade ago we we had a
huge
far higher number over a hundred
thousand at one point when tony blair
was prime minister last year the numbers
were down
to around about 30 000 and if you look
at the
the trend over the last five years and
as i say the last decade it's a downward
trend
nevertheless the numbers as douglas
rightly says
coming across the channel have increased
and that of course
poses a chat poses a big challenge
for our government and it would do for
any government of any color
because when you have people coming
across
one of the world's busiest shipping
lanes in
very small boats risking their lives
that that is a huge
issue and it has to be addressed but the
context is really important here the
overall context
is that the numbers coming to this
country seeking asylum
over the last few years and over the
last decade has been declining and it's
important to
to recognize that
several several things about that one is
of course it's not surprising that the
asylum plays were down
last year because most of the world was
in lockdown
um and it's it's it's very hard to draw
the trajectory of the last decade not
least also because of the movement
you're talking about of course
uh in the in the previous decade under
labour was significantly to do with
intra-eu migration
uh it was to do with the british
government losing control of the british
britain's borders
uh in part because of our membership of
the eu one of the things
that caused the british public to vote
to leave the eu in 2016
was the idea that the british government
would be more capable of controlling the
british borders
after leaving the eu than it was before
so that's why it's a particular
political problem for this government
movement migration ebbs and flows but if
after a government has been
mandated by the public with with tidying
up
its asylum and immigration system and in
fact is seen to be losing control
of it in such a visible way then i think
this is a problem
and and just one other point on this
which is that
it's important of course to bear in mind
this whole issue of the signal that you
give out
as a country the people who are trying
to cross the channel
illegally at the moment have gone
through multiple safe countries before
doing so
they do not have to come to britain they
are
choosing to come to britain they do not
have to pay the smuggling gangs
thousands of pounds to go across the
channel
they are choosing to do that and
choosing to leave
safe eu countries and if the government
in the uk
encourages that movement then as i say
the number of people who will like to
follow
is limitless because we are talking here
not just about people who are fleeing
for instance
afghanistan iran iraq
but as we saw recently in the surge of
arrivals the other week
uh people from vietnam for instance
there are people from sub-saharan africa
north africa across the world people who
are suffering economic deprivation
who would like to come to the uk and who
the uk cannot allow to come
but just on that and douglas as he just
uh
put across there but also in his cover
piece um talks about the fact that
the current arrangement privileges those
who can afford
entry can afford to make that journey
and also encourages people smugglers
do you agree with that look i think it's
really important here to understand the
context
even when we had inward migration from
the eu
the main countries of those
nationalities coming here seeking asylum
were not from the european union that
that was a that was a separate migration
challenge this is an issue which goes
back
right to when this country and it's and
and we're talking about it on on a very
significant day seven decades since this
country along with other countries
put its name to the u.n convention on
refugees
and conservative prime ministers since
churchill all the way up to david
cameron
have stuck to a very important principle
and that principle is that those people
who come to this country
claiming that they need protection
should be given a fair hearing on uk
soil
and if they need protection they should
be given it and if they don't need
protection
they should be sent back and indeed
today in the front line in the fight
against covid if you look at people
working
in the nhs there are afghan doctors who
had no choice but to get here
in the back of the lorry there are
people who came from iran
fleeing oppression who are top level
surgeons
and indeed if you look across the arts
if you look across education
if you look across business there are
many refugees who are making an
incredible contribution to this country
proud to be britain's playing by the
rules
paying their taxes and contributing to
this country
in an incredible way and it's very
important that as a nation
we continue seven decades after the un
convention
to stick to that key principle that as i
say many conservative prime ministers
have continued to stick to
which is if you come here with a case
for refugee protection you are given a
fair hearing
um there are two important things to say
about that the first is
um just to address the
fiction that the arrivals coming over by
boat
from france are all going to end up
being surgeons doctors
leading academics and statisticians and
much more it's not the case
uh it's the fantasy of the pro open
borders lobby
uh that everybody can i just say
sorry to interrupt but i'm not
advocating pro borders why am i
simply advocating if you let me finish
please charles come on
you've had a lot to say um what i am
advocating
is the un convention on refugees now the
u.n convention on refugees just let me
finish
please let me make my points i'm not
interrupting you the u.n convention on
refugees
is very clear and it upholds the
principle
that if you are fleeing oppression war
terror
and you come to this country you can
make
a claim for protection and indeed we
have done that for decades there are
many people across this country who've
come from afghanistan
indeed we we brought together refugees
early this week
across seven decades people that had
fled idi amin in uganda
people that had fled hungary in the
communist totalitarian regime
all individuals that came here made a
claim for protection
under the un convention and we're given
protection what i'm advocating
is that we adhere to that by no means am
i advocating open borders because if
people don't have a legitimate claim for
protection
or need for protection absolutely they
should be sent back to the country
from which they have come from and they
should be supported to do that
i'm very glad to hear you say that but
yet you're encouraging the breaking of
the law and the breaking of the asylum
procedures
by advocating or indeed encouraging the
illegal movement of people across the
channel
and as i say we have an asylum system in
convention
you said a moment ago that you hadn't
interrupted me and you just have again
it's extremely deleterious for our
country to be in a situation where we
encourage
the breaking of the law by migrants who
you then pretend afterwards are going to
never break the law again and they're
all going to become doctors and surgeons
but let's just address the bigger issue
which is a fundamental one which is that
you know as well as i do
the u.n convention for the uk is a
polite fiction
it relies on the the the
of it not being the case that very many
people are going to make it to the uk
and then claim asylum the people you
talked about who come from for instance
afghanistan have as i say walked across
multiple safe countries they are looking
at
europe as a buffet that they choose from
not as
a haven to try to reach and it is
exceptionally important that we as a
country understand this
in the modern context you keep talking
about context let's address the context
the context we are in now is very
different from that seven
decades ago we have not just the ability
to see how the rest of the world is
living through our smartphones and much
more and people across
africa have these devices but we can go
and move around
much more easily than at any time
previously in the current era
there are people from across the middle
east the far east
north africa sub-saharan africa all
wishing to move to europe and
britain is one of the countries they
would like to come to one third of
people in sub-saharan africa
polled by gallup last year said they
would like to move
they do not want to move to the middle
east they want to move to europe they
want to move
northwards now my suggestion is that in
that context
britain has to be realistic about what
our capabilities
are of providing a haven for the world's
poor dispossessed and much more
i think we are a small country we should
have
small ambitions about this we cannot be
a haven
for anyone in the world who wishes to
have a better life to come in and try to
make that better life here
it's impossible but as i say we've been
running on the polite fiction
of recent decades and i'd like us not to
keep up that fiction
and just just on that do you think the
current situation is sustainable if we
look at the
the current numbers is that a situation
that can go on
well the the numbers are down but you
know i'm not interested in arguing about
numbers i'm interested
in us as a nation
approaching this with compassion and
committing to
what i think has always been a great
british value that
as i say many conservative prime
ministers have been proud
to adhere to which is that if people
come here with a
with the need and a claim for protection
that should be looked at
and if they have a need that meets the
threshold they should be given
protection
and we have done that for seven decades
as i say
if you go around this country it was
really fascinating katie i actually did
an interview
about this on sky news this morning and
the percent
the presenter himself said to me look my
family
came here fleeing a totalitarian regime
in europe and were given protection here
under the convention
and that says to me that the you know he
he's his family
and his background is not an isolated
case there's many many people
that will be watching this that will
have connections through their families
to individuals who have come here and
have been given protection
if they need protection and that's
something that we should be proud of as
a nation
to be compassionate and to give people
that opportunity to to have safety and
protection here
and we should continue to do that and
douglas
in your piece you talk about the need
for a tougher uh response in terms
of the government's response what do you
think they should be considering
a whole range of proposals the first is
they could follow the example the greeks
have set in the last couple of years and
simply turn around the boats
in the channel that'd be much preferable
to the british coast guard effectively
acting as a wing of the smuggling
operation by
picking people up a few miles into the
channel and then referring them to the
uk
uh they could try to follow the
australian president
and offshore people wishing to come make
sure that their
applications are processed elsewhere
than on british soil
uh because as environs in actual fact
once you're in it's extremely hard for
the british government to repatriate is
it's it's all sorts of
reasons why they don't do it and why it
ends up not happening or being kicked
down the road
and another option is to follow our um
colleagues and friends in denmark
who have managed to introduce numerous
restrictions in recent
years to ensure that migration into
denmark has gone down by somehow
nine times in the last few years so you
know australia
greece denmark these are also very
distinguished liberal democracies they
all have a fine liberal tradition
and they've also realized that they can
hold on to the principle of legality
and of borders and that they can do so
without anyone but a very relatively
small fringe of people claiming that
they are
some kind of beyond the pale countries
and for which of those options do you
think
has merit well i
i think this is a global issue very much
in the way that climate change is a
global issue and of course it's a
challenge for every western government
when you have people who are being
displaced on the scale that we do have
globally today
you know millions and millions of people
being displaced through no faults
of their own and indeed if there was
displacement in europe
and europeans were being subject to what
is happening in other continents
i think europeans would expect the rest
of the world to respond in a
compassionate way
too so globally we have to think about
how we address
this huge challenge and the challenge
will continue
no doubt going forward into the future
years into the future
decades and it requires western
governments to come together in the way
that they're doing over climate change
and to think about a solution that
reflects
the principles that that nations have
abided by and stuck to and supported
since the horrors of the second world
war principles that are about
humanity they're about recognizing that
we are a global community and we
we respond appropriately to support
fellow humans when they're in crisis and
when they're in need of support
and they need to come together in in and
form a multilateral
agreement to respond to that right
across europe because it's a challenge
as douglas says for european nations
but that response needs to be based on
principles as i say of humanity
and compassion principles that that many
many nations many of those liberal
democracies
that douglas refers to are very proud to
to to sign up to and that's what needs
to drive
the response to this crisis in the same
way that governments are coming together
to use a set of principles in response
to the climate crisis
um i agree this is a global crisis but i
think that people talking about
britain's borders very rarely have any
idea of the global scale of it
when people talk about the need for
compassion and humanity
i don't think anyone is anti-compassion
or anti-humanity
i think these are very easy ways to
browbeat people into accepting the
breaking of the laws of the country that
they're in
it is not a british tradition or
anything of which britain needs to be
proud to pretend that britain is not
britain
unless we allow the breaking of the law
in our asylum and immigration policies
the fact that historically britain has
on occasion
been able to give sanctuary to really
very significantly small numbers of
people in our history
is a reflection that we're a small
island with relatively small resources
in the global scheme of things
and when people say that that we need to
come together to answer this i agree
with this
britain however cannot be the resort of
choice
for anybody in the world as they say we
have the example of people coming from
vietnam again the other day across the
channel
for anyone across the far east the
middle east the near east
sub-saharan africa north africa and
everywhere else in the world
where they are not having the life they
would like some people are fleeing war
zones absolutely the majority are
fleeing economic deprivation
and it is a very negative idea indeed
to my mind to pretend and to console our
consciences
by pretending in any way that britain
can answer
all of these problems we cannot what we
can do is make things an
awful lot worse in britain and in france
in neighboring eu countries by adhering
to a polite lie
that it is remotely in britain's gifts
to solve
all of the problems that exist in the
world and as i say
in particular by pretending that as well
as the
legal asylum system we have we should
also have a parallel
asylum system an illegal one where
whoever gets across
the channel first in a boat wins entry
into britain
i think it's a great mistake and the
people who have been encouraging it
will rue the day when this gets more out
of control down the line
it is something that will need to be
addressed and if it isn't we've seen in
the last decade what happens i've heard
all of the arguments about compassion
and humanity made by compassionate and
pseudo-humanitarian figures
across scandinavia mediterranean europe
they all said in the last 10 years let
them come let us answer the
the woes of the world and then it got
way out of hand and they had to crack
down
and snap back of course they did because
surprise surprise it's not in denmark's
gift to sort out the world's woes it's
not in sweden's gift
not in italy's gift and it's not in
britain's either
it's in the world's gift to respond to
global challenges in the way that we're
responding to the climate challenge and
of course
it's in the world's gifts and and the
gift of of democratic nations to
response
to respond to this challenge and i'm not
suggesting that britain
opens it its borders i'm simply
suggesting that as a nation
we uphold a principle that we stuck to
for seven decades which
is giving protection to those who need
it those that come across the channel
are not all economic migrants some of
them will be but if you look at the main
nations that they're coming from they're
coming from
syria they're coming from eritrea where
there's a huge issue
with refugee camps due to the war in in
ethiopia and the struggle the civil
struggle in ethiopia
they're coming from iraq we know the
situation in iraq
and they're coming from a highly
oppressive regime in iran
we need to give them the opportunity to
have their case heard and if they
merit protection we should give them
protection in the way that we have done
for many many decades and the
communities that have settled in this
nation as a consequence
of our commitment to refugee protection
have made a huge contribution to this
nation
indeed if you look at parliament you
could track back
through many parliamentarians lives and
families
those refugees that have come here
indeed our foreign secretary dominic
rabb
is one example of that and on that
envelope
one very quick this is that it's a
massive fallacy on this which is that
because you have have
some benefits from some migrants through
migration
the the an answer is the more uh
people come the more benefits will
accrue and it's simply not the case
none of the data bears that out because
as well as the good news stories that
envelope has just described
there are also very many bad news
stories
and for every one person who contributes
to the economy by becoming a surgeon
many others will be going into the black
market will be living very
unhappy lives in britain on the margins
of society that they have entered into
by first of all consorting with
smuggling gangs and then entering the
black economy
and i'm just fed up of having spent
years hearing
people pretending that if you make it to
a country like britain
you will end up inevitably in the
position of surgeon or academic
it's a terrible falsehood built upon an
existing falsehood
which as i say is our asylum aims of
recent decades
and just finally on that i mean in your
work you
offer support to those coming to the
country
what do you think is the case when it
you know reality meets
what people have expected in advance
i mean the reality is all those people
we we work with
when when they come here whether that's
through so-called regular routes
or the irregular routes that that
charles is so
uh seems to be so angry about first of
all it's douglas
sorry sorry
sorry i i do apologize that was my
oversight it wasn't an
intended uh mistake sorry douglas
um those irregularities that people come
come here too
um whether that's from afghanistan or
other countries
uh what we find is is when they arrive
here they are
hugely grateful for the support that
this country is offering them
and they want to make a contribution
they want to
do right by this country and they simply
want to rebuild their lives
they want to do the best for themselves
and for their families
and they know that doing the best for
themselves is by working hard
and by making a contribution and i think
what stands out from research
by ones and by other reputable research
agencies is that communities that have
come and settled in this country
are often the communities who are
extremely hardworking who do play by the
rules
and who do pay their taxes and are
upstanding
citizens who want to contribute to this
community to their communities
and we need to recognize that you know i
don't want to have an argument about
what is true
and untrue i want to have an argument
about the reality
based on our work and you know i'm sat
here from leeds today
we're welcoming a family that's coming
in from lebanon from a refugee camp
today
they will arrive they will be taken to a
home in york supported by the council
and i'm certain that that family will go
on to make an active contribution
to their community i was reading the
other day about
the woman who leaves the con and has set
up the conservative supporters and
friends of afghanistan
she came over here with her father in a
refrigerator
their only choice was to come on a
so-called irregular route
what douglas calls illegal roots they
came here
and now they're making a huge
contribution to this country and it's
important to reflect the reality
of those stories in this conversation
sure well
um you said you didn't want to talk
about facts or what was true and what
wasn't true you said you wanted to talk
about your work but let me introduce a
fact
to it which is that what you've just
said again
is incorrect a study from university
college london
10 years ago it showed that over the
previous
two decades the the amount of money
that migrants took out of the state
in benefits was hundreds of millions
of pounds less than what they paid in in
taxes so hundreds of million pounds more
than what they paid in taxation it takes
years
for a migrant into the uk to pay back in
taxation
what they take out in benefits it's very
basic economics
is the you know the the university
college london
study proved this it doesn't even
require
a study from a university it simply
requires and
any observation of the fact that the
moment that you come into the uk and
start
using uk facilities and uk services you
are taking money out of the uk taxpayers
pot
and you may pay some of that back in you
may in rare cases pay
all of it in but the idea that migrants
particularly illegal migrants arrive in
the uk and become a net
a net benefit to the uk is a fallacy
the benefits of migration of this kind
financially
accrue solely to the migrant and the
family of the migrant they do not come
to the uk
so again we could agree that the uk
should be a destination for anyone in
the world who wants to make
their lives better i don't think that
that would be desirable
but at the very least even if that was
the case that was being made we
shouldn't
build a polite fiction on a polite
fiction and pretend that people who
arrive
become a net economic benefit to the uk
because the figures don't bear that out
distinction i'm not talking about all
migrants i'm talking about those that
have been given refugee status
under our laws and under the convention
which we have
decided to adhere to over the last seven
decades
those who are given refugee status make
a phenomenal contribution to this
country i'm not talking about war
migration
i'm talking about those that get refugee
status and that is a specific
group of individuals who are given
status they're given indefinite leave to
remain
for five years and then they go on to
give to be given
uh status here
but why is it in britain's interest why
is it in britain's
interest to to to to to allow those that
are fleeing war and oppression to
rebuild their
issue all life and i think we might
disagree on it because i don't think we
can give
it back i think actually i think i asked
you what the evidence is of the economic
benefits of um migrants who enter the uk
illegally contributing to the uk economy
i'm not talking about migrants who enter
the uk illegally you're talking across
purposes to me douglas i'm talking about
individuals who come here
who make a claim for refugee protection
and get refugee state to succeed
benefit to the uk they make a huge
benefit to the uk
what is it through a whole range i don't
i
was about all migration i'm not talking
about all migration you're talking
you're having a conversation with me
about at cross purposes
indeed if you talk i think we are
because we're talking about
individuals who get status that is
regularized
where they're here legally as as
individuals with legal entitlements and
legal rights
yes yeah the university's london report
i just cited was not talking about the
black economy because nobody can measure
the black economy he was talking about
he was talking about talking about my
migrants
in in in totality in the previous
decades now
i'm not talking about migrants
whether you have a fact about this
because if what you're contending is
true
it means that of the migrants who arrive
in the uk
a vast majority take out more in
benefits than they put in
in taxation except for except for
people who have come to the uk seeking
asylum and have been given asylum
it would mean that as it were these were
the super migrants who provided
such an exceptional level of
contribution back to the uk economy that
they made up among others for those
who had entered without an asylum
application there is no data to back
this
up it would be highly surprising if it
was the case but it is one of the
reasons why this debate is
is so woeful because it is very
possible to talk about this purely in
moral terms it is
desirable to talk about it in moral
terms but it's also necessary if you're
going to introduce finances to it and
the contributions that people make
to also talk about the fact as i say
that
many if not most of the people arriving
and making a claim
will not become a scholar will not
become a doctor will not become an eye
surgeon
they will be entering at a low scale in
the economy they will be taking out more
in benefits than they put back in
taxation and we should at least look at
that full
picture instead of engaging in the
pretense that
everybody who comes is going to be an
amazing overwhelming benefit to the uk
economy into uk society
it's part of the fiction built upon
fiction which i deeply object to in this
discussion
and we're just to bring this
conversation to the end because we do
have to wrap up now
um in response to douglas is your view
that actually remember having this
conversation about the positive impact
refugees bring to the country
that's something that cannot be answered
just by economics
i think economics is one element there's
there's the richness
of that that they bring as different
cultures to
communities that that's very much part
of
of of of british life you know if you if
you look at the representation
in our national sporting teams for
example reflects the richness the
different communities that have
contributed and come and settled
in this country if you look at the facts
around
our food culture around our culture
around the arts
you know huge rich contributions as a
consequence of people that have come
here
seeking protection and settled in
in communities across the country i
actually you know dispute that refugees
don't make
a net economic contribution just because
i don't have the stats to
hand i don't think that's necessarily
not the case from our experience at the
refugee council
you know having worked we came into
existence seven decades ago
and we've worked with many individuals
that have come here
seeking protection and got refugee
status
largely in our experience overwhelmingly
they go on and contribute to communities
they're not a drain
on the nation's resources and their
children go on
and contribute and it's important to
remember that you know these these
the people that came here the ones that
those that i was talking about that we
brought together earlier this week
to reflect seven decades since the year
in convention
they've had children their children had
children and they've all contributed in
huge and diverse different ways
to this country so i think it's
important to reflect that the
contribution is on
a multiple number of layers and the
reality is that as a nation
the fact that we have given so many
people refugee protection
i think makes us a richer nation and
makes a as a nation that
that has greater value and greater depth
across the land in a multiplicity of
ways could i just ask very quickly i
know we have to finish but can i ask
enver
is there anyone who comes illegally or
otherwise who doesn't contribute
i don't know what what what's your
question about illegally or otherwise
illegally or otherwise is there anyone
who arrives in britain you think who
doesn't contribute to the country
who doesn't make it richer economically
who doesn't make it richer
he doesn't make the money so i think if
you look at the syrian resettlement
program that david cameron championed
and brought in
there's no doubt that that some of the
syrians that came here were from very
poor low-skilled communities
but our evidence of working and we're
one of the agencies that
has resettled people from syria from
from the horrors of what's happened in
syria
our our experience of working with them
is that they've been
extremely dedicated extremely committed
wanted to get jobs wanted to to acquire
the skills to contribute
and not become a drain on the nation's
resources
is that everybody contributes if it's
that tenacity
and dedication and commitment that
ultimately results in them contributing
more than they take so matt said
there will of course you know amongst
any cohort there will of course be some
who don't manage to do that that that's
the same you know you could take a
school
of children and you could look at you
know how many of those children might
end up
you know in the criminal justice system
being a net drain on resources
or you know living on benefits
in the same way in that cohort you'll
have the same in this cohort but in
general
you think yeah you think in general but
it is that it is
at the very least at the level of the
british public as a whole
and most likely most people come make a
contribution that's that's
clearly what you think and in that case
the more the merrier
the more people that can come into the
uk the better if that's your position
it's not mine
it's not the position of the british
public who do not believe that the
country
has a more than merrier situation i'm
not arguing for an open borders
policy and actually the the views of the
public
the views the views of the british
policies
that comes from migration i'm not
talking about
overall migration douglas this is where
you're misunderstanding
and even about the principle of refugee
protection which is not
migration it's a principle set down in
the euro convention
that we give protection to those who
need protection that's what i'm talking
about
and actually if you look at if you look
at the lead
if you look at politics recently done
by icm for british future the majority
of people
polled felt that it was important to
continue to adhere to the principles set
out in the ewing convention
yes and i'm trying to get you to
understand one single thing which is the
possibility that even
somebody who is given asylum it's not
necessarily the case that the more the
better
it might be in individual cases and in
general a case of the more the worse
and there would be so much more gained
if that was acknowledged
as i say there will indeed be some who
of course
don't contribute as much as others but
i'm saying the majority but in general
the majority the vast majority will
contribute
and will go on to make an important
contribution to play by their rules to
pay their taxes and to be proud to call
themselves britons
and with that this is a presumption but
it's not backed up by the evidence and
with that we are going to have to leave
that there now
thank you ender thank you douglas
[Music]
you